this video is kindly sponsored by
scentbird more on them later in the
video
hey 42 here if ridley scott's science
fiction masterpiece alien is to be
believed the creature known as xenomorph
xx121
is the perfect organism it can survive
in an extremely wide range of
environments including brief periods in
the vacuum of space
its shining black exoskeleton is
impervious to harm from all but the most
devastating of attacks
its whip-like tail is a lethal weapon
that can strike from distance and its
extendable jaws will rip you apart if
you're foolish enough to get in too
close
if you do somehow manage to injure this
ferocious beast its highly acidic blood
will melt your face off before you get
the chance to press your advantage
xenomorphs are also remarkable athletes
running jumping swimming
you name it stick one of these guys in
the olympics and you'd have water on the
phone demanding a urine sample within
minutes
combine all of that with a high degree
of intelligence and you're left with an
organism whose perfection is matched
only by its hostility
sadly i think these magnificent beasts
don't appear to exist in our little
corner of the universe but it turns out
that right here on earth lives a
creature
every bit as impressive perhaps even
more so
like the fearsome xenomorph this animal
has a tough exoskeleton and a whip-like
tail
and with 10 eyes and 10 legs it actually
trumps ridley scott's alien in at least
two departments
just like the xenomorph this animal is
incredibly tough and able to survive in
a variety of environments including both
underwater and on land for extended
periods of time it even has acid for
blood okay so i made that one up but its
blood does have unique and powerful
properties properties that make it one
of the most valuable liquids on planet
earth
this mystery creature truly is earth's
answer to the perfect organism
it must be doing something right anyway
because it's lived here for very close
to half a billion years making it one of
the most ancient animal species ever
identified
without further ado let me introduce you
to the most incredible animals who have
ever existed on earth
the horseshoe crab
[Music]
okay so it might not look quite as
impressive as a xenomorph at first
glance although you have to admit it
does give off a bit of a facehugger vibe
but seriously amongst the trillions of
species that have lived and died on
earth in the last 3.7 billion years or
so the horseshoe crab may just be
the most remarkable
if that sounds hard to believe i'm
confident you'll have changed your mind
by the end of this video
if you're anything like me you know that
buying a new fragrance can be a daunting
and expensive task sure one smells nice
in the store but you have a few seconds
to make that call before you need to
fork over a large sum of money to buy a
large bottle of the stuff and just hope
you still like how it smells in three
months time that's why scent bird is so
great scentbird is a subscription
service for fragrance just like netflix
lets you watch many titles for a single
price scentbird enables you to receive
fragrances from over 600 brands like
prada gucci and versace as well as indie
labels like vince camuto the harmonist
and confessions of a rebel in fact
they'll even help you to find your most
suited sense through their simple quiz
previous purchases and preferences
scentbird then sends you a 30-day supply
so instead of spending 150 to 500 on
just one bottle of fragrance with
scentbird you can get a luxury fragrance
for just seven dollars using my code and
all the scents come with their own
stylish colorful case scentbird is
available in the us and canada so make
sure you use my coupon code
4055 for 55 off meaning it's just seven
dollars for your first month
use the link in the description below to
try scentbird today when talking about
ancient species you'll often hear
scientists or david attenborough types
explain that such and such a species
lived when dinosaurs still walk the
earth it's the gold standard in species
longevity but it turns out that
horseshoe crabs didn't just cohabit
earth alongside the dinosaurs
they evolved
250 million years
before dinosaurs
even existed
the oldest horseshoe crab fossils found
so far date back about 480 million years
and they look almost identical to the
living breathing animals still found in
our oceans to this day 480 million years
is a genuinely absurd amount of time for
one species to have survived we're
talking more than 10 percent of earth's
entire history to put that number into
context our species homo sapiens have
been around for a measly
0.004 percent of the lifespan of our
planet
meaning the humble horseshoe
is about two and a half thousand times
more ancient
than we are these epic survivors were
around when the supercontinent pangaea
formed
and they watched it break apart again
over the following hundred million years
or so
they survived largely unchanged for at
least three significant ice ages and
they're one of a tiny number of higher
animals to have made it through four of
earth's five mass extinction events if
you've watched my recent video on the
great dying
you'll know it was the deadliest mass
extinction in earth's history especially
for anything unfortunate enough to live
in the era's boiling acidic oceans
conditions there were so inhospitable
that an estimated 96
of marine species were lost
the horseshoe crab
was part of the four percent
perhaps we shouldn't be too surprised
that these guys have survived so long
though i mean if you asked a game
designer to come up with a biotank
concept for some fictional alien species
it will probably look a fair bit like a
horseshoe crab but whilst they may look
pretty scary unless you're a worm or a
small crustacean they're actually almost
entirely harmless
their large size and self-healing
exoskeletons keep them safe from the
majority of potential predators
and whilst that's spiny tail may look
pretty vicious it's rarely if ever used
offensively in fact it isn't even used
defensively it's basically a robot war
style self-writing mechanism that's
employed if the crab ever gets flipped
over in the surf
though it certainly isn't obvious from
looking at them horseshoe crabs actually
have 10 eyes of varying sophistication
and they can detect ultraviolet as well
as visible light the main set are
compound eyes like those found in
insects and the rest are spread across
the animal's body and tail including a
pear on the animal's underside that
might sound like an odd place to keep a
set of eyes but believe it or not
horseshoe crabs do actually make good
use of them
most of the time the crab crawls around
on the ocean bottom but when they come
across a barrier that defeats the
combined effort of their ten legs
they take to the water and swim
upside down and when you're flopping
around arse over tit in the middle of
the ocean being able to see out of your
gooch is actually pretty handy if you're
wondering why horseshoe crabs swim
upside down in the first place that's
because they propel themselves through
the water by pulsing their respiratory
organs that's a bit like swimming by
flapping your lungs
these unusual organs known as book gills
are located on the crab's underside
at such an angle that makes swimming the
right way up almost impossible as well
as necessitating one hell of a weird
swimming stroke these buck gills are the
reason horseshoe crabs can survive out
of water for so long up to four days in
fact provided the gills stay moist i say
that book gills are unusual because no
other crab species has them in fact
they're more commonly found in the form
of book lungs in spiders and scorpions
the reason for this art discrepancy is
simple
horseshoe crabs aren't actually crabs at
all nor are they even particularly
closely related to crabs
as for what they are instead
well the truth is we still aren't 100
sure but recent research seems to
suggest they are in fact arachnids
making them more closely related to
spiders and scorpions than crabs and
lobsters rather fittingly for these
kings of survival horseshoe crabs have
bright blue blood that's because they
use copper-containing hemocyanin rather
than oxyhemoglobin to transport oxygen
around their bodies but horseshoe crab
blood isn't just nice to look at it's
also incredibly valuable a single liter
of the stuff is worth around fifteen
thousand dollars making it one of the
most expensive liquids on earth behind
scorpion venom and everyone's favorite
luxury liquid horse semen as for why
people pay so much for horseshoe crab
blood it turns out it's literally
magical okay not magical but it's pretty
amazing stuff so amazing in fact that
there's a fair chance
you owe your life to it
if you've ever been given a vaccine a
pacemaker an artificial heart valve an
artificial joint or pretty much any
intravenous injection of any kind
you probably owe a debt of gratitude to
the humble horseshoe crap
you see their weird blue blood contains
cells called amoebocites which form a
gel-like goo in the presence of harmful
bacteria that may not sound like such a
big deal but when scientist frederick
bang discovered this unusual property in
the 1950s
it was an absolute game changer for the
pharma industry
at the time there was no easy way to
determine whether medical equipment and
intravenous drugs were contaminated with
dangerous bacteria if for example you
wanted to check that a vaccine was free
of toxins you had to first inject it
into rabbits then wait a few days and
see if any of them died
it was expensive it was time consuming
and it absolutely sucked if you were a
rabbit
frederick bang realized he could harness
the unique properties of horseshoe crab
blood to test for toxins far more
efficiently in the crabs amoeba sites
form a protective gel barrier around any
bacteria that happens to infiltrate the
crab's bloodstream preventing it from
spreading the cells are so finely tuned
to the presence of harmful bacteria that
they can detect toxins at levels of less
than one part per trillion it took him
20 years but eventually dr bang
developed a reliable test that in as
little as 45 minutes could be used to
ensure that medical devices drugs and
vaccines were free from potentially
lethal bacterial contamination
as great as this discovery was for us
and for rabbits come to think of it it's
been less than ideal for horseshoe crabs
the lal test as it's known has been an
absolutely vital part of the healthcare
industry for the last four decades
but we've needed increasingly vast
quantities of horseshoe crab blood to
fulfill the demand every year more than
half a million horseshoe crabs are
harvested from the world's oceans for
bloodletting
which is about as pleasant as it sounds
horseshoe crab bleeding glabs literally
look like something out of a sci-fi
horror film the companies involved in
blood extraction do at least aim to only
take as much as the crabs can spare but
as you can probably imagine being
whisked up out of the ocean strapped
into a device designed to drain your
blood alongside thousands of your mates
isn't exactly pleasant as many as 30 of
horseshoe crabs are fought to die in the
process there are also rumors that some
bloodletting companies don't bother
returning the crabs to sea at all and
instead simply sell whatever survives to
the fishing industry
around half a million horseshoe crabs a
year are used as bait to catch eels in
the u.s alone the sad thing is a
synthetic alternative to the lal test
has actually been around for almost 20
years but uptake in the farmer industry
has been slow and our reliance on
horseshoe crabs remains as strong as
ever
why
it's complicated but it could be that
extra validation steps are required when
using the synthetic alternative which
adds time to vaccine development
and some argue it's also less reliable
than the real deal
considering the amount of pressure we're
putting on their numbers it probably
shouldn't come as much of a surprise
that horseshoe crabs are under threat
and things are only getting worse
particularly with demand for their blood
going through the roof over the last few
years as pharmaceutical companies have
been racing to develop covert 19
vaccines
it doesn't help that it's extremely
difficult to breed horseshoe crabs in
captivity
so whenever we need them we pretty much
always have to catch them in the wild
half a billion years is plenty of time
to get set in your ways and one of the
horseshoe crabs more unusual foibles is
that they don't seem to breed unless
they're in the presence of the same
substrate they were spawned in how
exactly they're able to tell the
difference
we literally have no idea
apparently they just
know
whilst i admit the xenomorph comparison
i made at the start of this video may
have been just a tiny bit ambitious
there's no denying that horseshoe crabs
are truly amazing creatures of the
trillions of species that have lived and
died on this planet
the fearsome carnivores the apex
predators the giants of land and sea
it's these ridiculously weird and
unassuming little animals that have
proven themselves to be the ultimate
survivors
overcoming ice ages and asteroid strikes
just like they were minor inconveniences
it really would be a terrible tragedy if
their half a billion year existence on
planet earth
was brought to an end because of us
thanks for watching
don't forget to try scentbird and use my
coupon code 4055 for 55 percent off
that's just seven dollars for your first
month it's a great service with some
amazing fragrances so don't miss out the
links in the description below